29 strikeouts
in 19 in the third innings of work he's
been composed he keeps saying it's weird
to pitch
in front of well nobody but you would
think that he's
his heart rate is so rhythmic anyway
he doesn't get the face yeah i was gonna
say it wouldn't be that big of a deal
but
he was smiling when he said it brandon
nemo leads off against aaron nola
and nola with a 2-2 pitch swung out and
missed strike three well that was the
change up and that just
about dropped off the table it appeared
and so brandon nemo down on strikes
and dom has hit home runs in three
straight games
for the second time in his career that's
pulled down the line and dom smith's got
himself a base head
jd around second on his way to third dug
out by harper and they're gonna hold jd
at third base
as dom smith comes through again this
time he pulls a double down the right
field line
his sixth double of the year and the
mets have second and third and two out
now steven metz is going to get
straightened out in a ballpark
that has not been particularly friendly
to him never mind most other pitchers
and he strikes him out with a change up
so matt's who's been using this change
up this year more than ever
gets the strikeout with the off-speed
pitch for the first down
gourmet hits one down the left-field
line slicing away from mccutcheon but he
runs it down
mccutchen who had that knee
reconstructed
after acl surgery turned on the jets to
take a hit away from guillermo
max has retired the first four and now
the veteran gene
segura that one's hit well out to left
field dominic smith going back
it is gone gene sigouras hit his third
home run of the year
and the phillies take a one-nothing lead
here at the bottom of the second
one too many change-ups and he got this
one up this first one i think he's
actually gotten up
and he paid for it was up it was a
little bit away out over the plate and
gene stayed right on it smoking for that
so there's the second
walk of the inning issued by nolan and
runners at the corners for dom smith
the 2-2 swinging a miss he struck him
out
got him with a breaking ball and down
goes dominic smith fifth strikeout for
nola and he really needed that one
puts out the fire for the mets no runs a
hit and two left we're going to the
bottom of the third it's one nothing
fittings
one nothing philly's top of the fourth
nola from the wind up here's the 0-1
swing and a little number to the right
side on a short hop hoskins has it he'll
flip to noah covering
and retire rosario good play by hoskins
that one
had some english on it he basically went
to a knee to field it
batter is bryce harper the walk-off base
hit last night that's nothing new for
harper the 0-1
harper bunts third base side charging in
for it is rosario
played a first and it is in time he gets
harper good play by ahmed rosario
as harper tried to bunt against the
shift rosario was the only man on the
left side of the infield
and he charged ahead toward the pitchers
mound on the left side
fielded cleanly made a strong
off-balance throw to first
and he got bryce harper by a step gene
segura bats
homart for the only philly run his first
time tonight the pitch
swinging a drive to center field nemo
comes in now over
and now he's got a beat on it he'll
reach up and make the catch about letter
high
and pretty well again by segura but he
is retired so are the phillies here in
the fourth phillies they're ahead one
nothing but how about one hit so far off
of stephen mats
came into this game with an 8 20 era but
he's pitched well there's mccutchen
who's over two
all four then i'll force it around the
phillies take a two-nothing lead
it'll be an rbi for mccutcheon his fifth
of the season as dd crosses the plate
there was a chance that that would have
been the last batter for him but they've
decided to hang with them
three walks now for mats they've all
come in the last two innings
and now hoskins who drew the first of
those walks
that one's lined the right center field
that'll split the gap and go to the
scoreboard
this may clear the bases this will clear
the bases
hoskins a three-run double and the
phillies busted open
it's five nothing here in the fifth and
as well
as mats was pitching it's five to
nothing and here's harper
that one's drilled toward right field
toward the scoreboard it hits the top of
the scoreboard
hoskins around third heading for home
the throw goes to second
and harper is safe at second base it's
an rbi
double six-nothing phillies swag
he got him eight strikeouts for nola and
he has been in total control he hasn't
allowed a hit since the third
seven scoreless innings under his belt
here tonight
here smith with that three home run
streak going
and dom cranks one out to right field
headed toward the wall
and it's out of here dom smith strikes
again
he homers for the fourth consecutive
game
to get the mets on the board on the
ninth home run number six
for dom and with two out nobody on
robinson canoe will be the better
fly ball left field mccutcheon goes back
he's under it makes the catch
and the ball game is over the fields
have won back-to-back games against the
new york mets